there is a tiger this is her home
territory where we're putting you she
has some Cubs she's killed 22 people
this year but it's okay she's only eaten
12 of them okay well then that's great
my odds are good Pam let's drought
hustle Nona Survivorman and this is the
breakdown this is into the wild this
kind of frantic sort of crawling around
behavior that is accurate at home we
might want to run into a bathroom or run
outside but in his state malnutrition a
starvation dehydration even that right
there you'd think you could drink water
to make it feel better but when you have
poison in your stomach even water in
your mouth is going to feel like poison
it's going to feel painful and so him
actually not swallowing the water was
spot on the thing about trying to
identify wild edible plants through
books you could have nine books in front
of you with photographs and line
drawings and descriptions you will just
never ever be a 100% certain there is
only one way to learn wild plants and
that's to have a teacher there showing
you when somebody says to you yes pick
it
oh go ahead and eat it oh you're too shy
okay here I'll show you see as soon as
you see somebody else put it in their
mouth you go okay I guess it's all right
when you start to learn what an edible
wild plant is you start to pay attention
to all of the nuances of plant
morphology the leaves are they spiked
are they smooth are they basal are they
around the stem there's all these
different descriptions and that's what
he's doing around here
lateral veins and then you hold it up
and you look are they lateral are they
vertical it's tricky to do that to this
day I will probably not chase tests a
plant until I've been able to find
somebody that knows I'm doing mushroom
season and I go out with friends I go
guys who really know their mushrooms to
know that I'm getting the right one in
the case of wild edible plants most
poisonous plants will just make you sick
maybe make you vomit but we're dealing
with an individual who's already
starving if he'd had a larder full of
food then even eating the
plant would have made him sick for a day
or two that's it and he would have
recovered this is gonna come back as a
refrain the use of the grizzly bear when
you start to get into states of
starvation
things become very surreal which is why
when this bear showed up
I wasn't sure if this was supposed to be
a dream the concept of a bear like that
just walking by as no that's not gonna
happen the likely case scenario is the
bear is not going to come close it's
going to more than anything stay away
from him and his bus I think Sean Penn
handled the confusion of the lot edible
plants and the books and the identifying
very well because it is confusing and
the bottom line the moral of the story
don't do it don't eat it if you don't
know 100% bigger scale my opinion of
Chris I think he was probably a very
wonderful man a lot of people liked him
he's been deified almost at this point
but he was a terrible survivalist he
didn't know anything oh no but he had
all those experiences what if you really
pay attention and check out his story
the truth is he always got out of things
by somebody else pulling him out
somebody always kind of helped him out
of bad situations when he got up to
Alaska there was nobody there to save
him he was probably a very charming very
well-spoken man Alaska doesn't give a
crap if you're charming I don't believe
Chris had to die I think with a few bits
of knowledge he could have gotten by
there he could have done things much
differently I know in the story he has a
moose and it spoils on him there were so
many ways he could have had that moose
last him the entire time he was there
but he didn't he just simply didn't know
how to do it this is the edge this is
one of those films I purposely didn't
watch it based on the poster alone
imagine you are a lawyer or your partner
is a doctor and they make a TV show out
of it you know you sit there going no
that's what I do when it comes to
survival films
if it's really that cold I know he's got
a little bit of the hand up to the mouth
thing the thing that you want to protect
the most is actually your head 80% of
your heat is lost through your head I
mean I'm bald and so for me a cap in the
wintertime is just vital otherwise I
really lose heat okay right there do you
see any footprints of him walking up to
that spot because I don't see any this
is what Hollywood just doesn't get it
all of that snow around him that should
be all mucked up it's like it was placed
there by the camera crane or something
here we're gonna put you down there and
we're gonna film the scene a grizzly
bear of that size can sneak up on you
that quickly and that's I'll I don't
know which bear this is and in Hollywood
terms it's probably Bart Bart the bear
is a famous bear used in so many films
nicely groomed bear by the way what
we're about to see is a bear attack and
a very silly one that grizzly is going
to come after you they run full steam
super fast much faster than you can and
a lot of times they're back two legs
they'll go in unison because they're
really pushing at it so what we have
here is an acting bear lollygagging
along behind him frolicking in the snow
here's a tip here the real thing to do
in the case of a grizzly bear attack is
to play dead the way I look at predators
we have what I think are accidental
predators and apex predators an apex
predator are those creatures on this
planet that truly would like to eat us
great white shark would truly like to
eat us not because we're prey or they
want to find us or anything like that
but because they're kind of haphazard
eaters they'll taste test stuff but the
way you react to a predator is going to
be different each time with a grizzly
you don't stand a chance can't outrun it
one thing you can do to a grizzly bear
is bore them they may taste test you
while they're getting bored which means
you might have to put up with a chomped
hand or something but you keep all the
extremities in and you curl up into a
ball and you get boring and you play
dead that said would you or I run damn
straight we'd run I'd probably run too I
can sit here and say I should play dead
but I'd be like maybe there's a chance
fare like that is not going to run
through those trees snapping them over
what's going to happen is they're all
green and growing and young they're all
going to bend and be pushed to the side
these things are snapping like dry
toothpicks have been standing there for
20 years dead you know what I guess I
could throw a little kudos here to one
thing if you are going to protect
yourself from an animal that big getting
in a grove of trees or a jumble of big
branches like that that actually is a
smart thing to do just a little behind
the scenes magic Bart the bear and the
other acting bears they never growl when
a grizzly bear growls he truly is angry
these guys are trained actors they've
taught the bear to just hang their mouth
open or even open their mouth with all
the saliva and the fangs in reality
there's zero sound coming out of their
mouth they have to dub all that in later
oh that's a pet peeve he's a man Killa
oh my gosh we've been fed that for a lot
of years even back in the days of the
movie Born Free it is that tiger a
maneater
or is it just enacting its own survival
the following is the whole time he's
stalking us
the torches if you can have a safe and
massive fire I'm talking like six feet
flames do it when they start throwing
these torches those torches are treated
by the special effects unit so that they
will not blow out as they throw them in
the air I've drawn lots of burning logs
in the air sometimes they stay going
most of the times they snuff out while
they're flying classic Hollywood the
grizzly bear growling off in the
distance that will happen with cats
not so much bears - guys the fire all of
that the Bears just gonna take off
running they're not gonna hover around
the outside growling but we always see
them in Hollywood films growling like
yeah I'll get you this is 127 hours
that's really true to course when you're
that dehydrated even a sprinkle of rain
or you're out there running around
trying to catch the drops this is a
really nice depiction of flash flight
I've seen rivers go up 20 feet in a
matter of a couple of hours my canoes
were about to get washed downstream it
you can imagine how fast that is and
that's the danger of flash floods they
don't have to happen where you are
they just have to happen uphill from
where you are the thing about this is
Aron Ralston who the film was made about
is an incredibly experienced adventurer
even though this is a dream sequence the
depiction of the reality on his face of
what's going on water wise is very real
people who do a lot of this kind of
adventuring can recognize the signs and
he knows he's in a crevasse that has
thousand crevasses leading to it and
every single one of those crevasses is
about to become a stream that's the
crazy part about a flash flood you have
to see it to believe it because it's not
like oh well we got time let's walk out
of the way let's go up higher mat walls
of water coming down the crevasse 15 to
20 feet high and try to get out of the
way that any course he's trapped a
little nuance that I like they didn't
have him calling for help so often the
scene in the film is already hopeless it
gets worse and then they start calling
for help so if you haven't had help for
12 hours all of a sudden you think
someone's gonna come now because you're
yelling and then that's a cool part this
is when rocks and big trees and lots get
moved around it's possible that this
water could have given that kind of
buoyancy and that force and push on the
rock to move it so that in his dream he
pulled his hand out I have to be careful
but I don't have to be careful some of
these films are made on real stories so
that one clearly is that's aron ralston
story the 127 hours the one thing during
that movie I wanted to talk with him
about was drinking his own pee for
dehydration and the reality is no that's
that's a no-go like no you do not do
that in a survival situation I think in
truth what he really felt was it was a
sense of comfort it wasn't necessarily
hydrating himself even though it's 92
percent water but there's all the toxins
and so on but here's the missing link
most the time when you're that
dehydrated you don't pee
this is the office an episode actually
called Survivorman producers contacted
me and said Michael Scott's gonna go out
and try to be you that couldn't have
been more honored this is the highlight
of my career I've got the DVD at home
it's sitting on my shelf you can bet
it's funny how right Steve Carell got
things now this way
I can't retrace my steps I don't know
what streets move it oh yeah I did that
i blindfolded myself and I had them
paddle me into the swamp he's mimicking
of me is so embarrassing Lennie spot-on
I was like God am i that cheesy am i
that bad please allow me to have one
cathartic experience in my life there's
a lot of weekend warriors that want to
have exactly what Michael just said they
want to have a cathartic experience
playing survivor man I will remain close
by done see that happened to me
I've had my crew go are you sure les can
we just like check in on you I've had to
argue with my crew if you go to do
something like this a lot of times the
people around it they won't let you in
the Arctic might one of my very first
episodes I had a hunter that watched me
from afar through his gun sights in the
Amazon jungle I had a native elder he
kept showing up I'm in the middle of the
jungle and I'm like a little catching
some shrimp and I'm filming I'm doing
this I'm doing Michael Scott's do and
I'm talking to the camera now I look
over and he's standing there and he's
just wanted to make sure that I'm okay
now everything I brought with me can be
used the stupid part about this is this
going to be hard for me to critique this
because he's copying a Survivorman
episode and he's kind of getting it
right so many episodes of mine I can't
watch anymore because I'm doing
something really stupid like that in
there Cook Islands I cut off the bottom
of my shirt to make a bandana it was
just super cool and stupid this can be
used for all sorts of okay in a real
survival situation what you would do is
you try to not damage anything that you
have unless you can repurpose it for
something better then you don't want to
be squeamish about damaging something
totally alone right now with only my
thoughts I love it
now I'm loving it when you're alone out
there you do some really silly stuff
it's cathartic if you're distraught you
might break down and bawl your eyes out
if you're angry I mean that argument you
had three days ago in the airport on the
way here ah I can't believe that she
said that you get it all out when you're
out there you know he made a mistake
cutting his pant legs off and then he
had to fix a mistake when you're super
hot at 2:00 p.m. you think everything's
gonna be fine and then at five-thirty
you're like huh and now you're wishing
you hadn't soaked your shirt in the lake
or something or in his case cut his pant
legs I tell you what bugs me halfway
through a survival episode my crew leave
me alone for seven days and I know that
on the day three when I'm really hungry
they're having a beer and a filet mignon
I have made this spear ridiculously
embarrassing
I made a spear that wasn't much
straighter than that and the Cook
Islands one time and I knew it wasn't
gonna work but I had to do something I
had to try well you know what you eat
when you're out there very little little
grubby things that's why you know a
highlight catching a scorpion or
crickets or something like that
that's what you really get nobody runs
and impales a rabbit you don't
accidentally come upon a sea bear that
you can just eat because it's laying
there in Africa with nobody touching it
well survival you grovel I have been
without food for a good three hours or
so now that's hilarious if my kids say
to me after two hours after lunch
oh god I'm starving so you realize
you've got the wrong father to say I'm
starving too people think that three
hours six hours without food and they're
going to perish
three days and you're still pretty lucid
and okay and without water with food
you'll get lethargic but you got ten
days of still being able to do things
without eating its greens birthday today
happy birthday to you there's a lot of
moments just like that not singing happy
birthday just sitting there
huh okay you have to get your mind
together you have to think about what
you're gonna do next it's actually a
good thing the truth about survival in a
survival situation and filming it is
that real survival is really boring you
hardly do anything you think about it
I'm out there for seven days you've got
a 43 minute episode that you watch
that's 43 minutes across seven days a
lot of that time nothing
that's the truth in reality of a real
survival situation it's not wham bam
thank you ma'am full of packed action
and just kind of sitting there singing
happy birthday this is life a pie I read
the book but I read the book after I saw
the movie you know I don't know what it
is the difference between filmmakers
when they try to depict certain scenes
that actually happen in life some just
do a silly job of it others nail it and
they make you feel every moment and this
is one of those films where you can feel
that door opening underwater and the
pressure difference everything so far so
good
when frantic scenes like this happen
it's a very difficult thing to get right
you can take the camera and Joss look
around like you're the character you can
slam it into walls and things but too
often Hollywood shows the the missteps
and the slips is ridiculously dramatic
which is fine if you're watching The
Avengers but if you're watching
something like this you know you want it
to be pretty spot-on to how someone
would slip on the deck how someone would
catch themselves what I love about this
scene is how quickly the boat slips away
from the main boat when the storm is
that crazy you can be out of reach of
your safety within a split second I'll
bet you in the brain it all happens in
slow motion but in real life it happens
this fast with waves like that you're
going to be tossed about you're nothing
more than a cork really I think they
depicted him being at the mercy of being
tossed from a ship as perfect as I can
imagine I tell you your voice can only
carry so far I've been on the other side
of a river with some basic rap it's not
even rushing rapid and young person on
the other side can't hear you
your voice does not cut through storms
and rain and wind and Forrest very well
at all whistles do
that's why whistles matter and survival
they cut through the sound they travel
long distance a lot better than you
yelling help it's one of the reasons why
I taught myself how to whistle if i
whistle right now I blow the microphones
out
now that little moment right there is
very true I've been in the ocean with
crazy waves trying to get on board small
vessels it is often the wave that will
get you on board when you know them you
can kind of tie meant that you know the
boats going up eight feet and down eight
feet you have to time getting on board
that boat with the waves so the tiger
did it right there's a few things going
on here number one him jumping ship it's
a fictional story so I can't even speak
to that one
seeing the immensity of the wave above
them that's a pretty real thing to see
going down below like this the instant
quiet that's one things I love about
diving it can be crazy but once you go
underneath surface it just goes quiet
they did throw in sharks swimming by for
dramatic effect and that's all that is
is dramatic effect yeah nicely and
beautifully done I don't know if he's a
free diver but you can get down that low
you can hover and I've done it watching
humpback whales this particular scene
they did beautifully in Life of Pi
this is open water I've done a lot of
shark dives I highly advise learning how
to dive and diving with sharks it's one
of the most amazing things you'll ever
do in your life they're set up here
people have been forgotten with
different companies that companies I
don't know especially local companies in
small countries I worry they go out with
25 people 26 people and they don't do a
headcount you don't pay attention to
anybody else you're looking at your own
gear and you're you know with your wife
or your husband or your partner I won't
comment on the acting but as far as the
scene goes this is how sharks operate
curious at first so they'll bump you and
they might bump you another six times a
tiger shark might try to taste-test the
tank on your back more testing of what
these two things up there are by the
sharks before an all-out attack it has
happened a shark has come out of nowhere
and attacked a diver before that has
happened so rare compared to the amount
of hours that humans are in the water
doing all of this to these activities
beautiful sharp
it actually does portray how he would
probably react to that because you get
angry when when you get hurt or at least
I do
in fact friends of mine know that if I
get hurt and I go silent I'm really hurt
but if I'm swearing up a storm no he'll
be fine you know now right there that
big chunk out of his leg would a shark
do that on a second bump highly unlikely
except for the great white most of the
Sharks are accidental predators they may
attack because of other reason things
are going on you know I mean spear
fishermen get attacked a lot because
they've got dead fish all over them bad
scripting my leg is still there right
the shark going after that little beacon
there it's been proven that sharks are
actually attracted to the color yellow I
think about that when you buy any sweat
suit and so the shark bumping that I
don't necessarily think the director
meant that to be biologically correct
but it accidentally was let's say she's
about to put a tourniquet on what a
controversial subject pendulum has
always swung the use of a tourniquet in
a survival situation for a while it was
used a tourniquet and it was never used
a tourniquet she was a tourniquet and
he's never used a tourniquet we're back
to pretty much using a tourniquet if
you've been given the proper
instructions so the idea with using a
tourniquet is you learn how to do it
properly just as you would get your CPR
or your first-aid training
so putting a tourniquet on him this is a
smart thing to do now I would have gone
top of my thigh that's higher just in
the crux there nonetheless it's still
the right thing to do one of the most
painful things you can ever feel in your
life is a tourniquet it hurts more than
the sharkbite the first time I ever
panicked under the water my dive
instructor took my head and held it like
that and then she went like this and she
just calmed me down and that's what's
going on in this scene she's kind of
doing the right thing in a survival
situation with that much panic would
there be more sharks you bet there would
be they can smell I can't remember the
statistic it's one of those crazy
statistics like a drop of blood in a
million gallons of water or something
like that there are going to be
different things you can do sharks are
like cats they do not want to attack you
from the front so I mean in India I wore
a mask on the back of my head so that a
tiger wouldn't pounce on me from behind
in the water when I see sharks you want
to make eye contact with a shark Chuck's
don't want to attack your face if I were
her I would have gone and just kept
looking just make sure the shark knows
you know it's there the answer to where
you should go to save yourself lies
entirely in what preparation did you do
before this what do you know do you know
that you are two miles west from a whole
archipelago do you know that you're a
quarter mile east of a very large island
do you know that do you know the
currents get all the information about
what you're the hike you're about to do
in Peru the dive you're about to go on
all of that information should be in
your head not just the guides head
because what happens when you lose the
guide you want to know where did you
leave from the boat how far out are you
can you make an attempt to swim to
safety because I certainly would want to
and if the guide doesn't want to give
you information you need to stop that
trip right there this is alive if we do
this we'll never be the same again
it's like communion from their death we
live people will understand I know this
story very very well and I can assure
you that the decision to engage in
cannibalism is not one you come by
easily if I have you for three days or
four days with no food and I show you
that we can eat scorpions and creepy
crawlies and I eat one in five you
you're not gonna hesitate give me some
of those and you're gonna eat
cannibalism total different thing it
should be good classic show of
leadership here that blank stare from
everybody these people thought they were
going to be damned to hell
some of these people struggled well
after their ordeal
I believe the Pope even absolved them
and assured them that they were still
going to heaven I mean wow the
psychological kickback from all this has
been intense so I hate to be technical
about it but gluttonous Maximus you're
going to engage in cannibalism that's
where all the meat is right I don't mean
any disrespect the reality is that the
glutes are the most exposed easiest
thing to get anything else requires
precision like surgery are going in and
maybe getting organs and things like
that I mean and think about how
horrifying to say you know what we
should eat the liver first what you do
in a situation of cannibalism is you try
to dehumanize the body laying in front
of you an animal that you catch can be
at one moment a cute and cuddly rabbit
and then when it's dead it's a piece of
meat you need to skin and roast that's
what they psychologically have to do
they have to take a look at the biggest
muscle on the body the place that is the
farthest away from the humanism the face
this is extreme survival there's no
question about it
I get asked where's the toughest place
to survive what I'll say is wherever
it's cold if it's cold it's hard
you can't stop if I'm in a really rugged
area and there's Jaguar around and
poisonous things but it's 75 degrees I'm
okay I got forgiveness time I can sleep
by a tree maybe when it's cold you can
succumb so quickly to hypothermia when
you don't have food in your system
what's there to keep your body engine
warm when it comes to cannibalism and
any survival situation you and I can not
judge a group of people on the verge of
potentially never being rescued and
potentially dying or having to make a
decision like this so you can't judge
and
there Jeremiah Johnson my favorite movie
of all time the consultant on this film
was none other than Larry Dean Olsen one
of the godfathers of survival what
follows are proper depictions of
survival first little slice of realism
is that this is the time of year when
the fish run in creeks like that I've
been in creeks with all the snow around
and suckers are just running like crazy
bouncing off your legs now you might be
asking why would he get himself all wet
like that well he's a desperate mountain
man looking for sustenance
he's going after fish well actually no
this was an accidental fight he was
trying to trap but he sucks at it this
is the very beginning of film and it's
the thing we think we can just go up
there and just be Jeremiah Johnson you
have to train you have to learn these
skills if you're going to try and catch
fish in a creek even when there's
hundreds of them it can be tricky
I thought maybe they're just busy about
their business until I started doing it
several times although they know you're
there they swim away from you quickly
why because you represent to them likely
a grizzly bear anything big that's
coming down along the water they don't
want to be around it so they try to take
off so it's very difficult now what
we're seeing here is gonna set up the
entire movie which is his friendship
with and then war with tribes that were
in the area that's a good look of
disgust right there now later on in the
film actually when he bumps into that
native leader again through translation
he says you fish poorly and he did we're
not looking at a seasoned mountain man
yet he's alone abhi this scene here I
love this fire scene because again I
know that Larry Dean Olsen was
consulting showing him this is how it
actually works with rock and steel and
charred cloth you take a hundred percent
cotton and you char it and then if you
put a spark on it it catches the spark
holds the Ember you put that in tinder
you blow it to flame that was their pack
of matches that's not like rubbing two
sticks together which is even more
primitive doing if the fire Boaz goes
back in time doing it with your hands
goes even farther back in time and
different geographical locations the
thing about getting a fire going is this
you've got to humble yourself and really
take your time I still don't understand
today getting regular camping how people
can't get a fire going with matches and
dry wood it just baffles me in the end
it's a skill set and one worth
practicing and he's about to blow it
well that's he done wrong he's got no
protection around him he's
out of the wind who doesn't have a big
supply of wood beside him you have to
treat your fire like it's your baby you
can do that you will get a great warm
fire going
the thing that Jeremiah Johnson portrays
beautifully is that the romanticism and
the power of being out in the mountains
are on horseback we're in the wilderness
alone it's still very very powerful is
it it's a soul experience I guarantee
you every man that has seen this movie
is playing Jeremiah Johnson in his head
when he only watches I could do doc yeah
the thing about Jeremiah Johnson and his
ability to live and survive in the
wilderness is he's just not instantly
good at it it takes a long time it comes
down in the end he's on the mountainside
and he's comfortable and he's roasting a
rabbit the character he meets in the
beginnings looks at him and just says
you've come far pilgrim my favorite line
of all time he just without even barely
look at him he just says feels like far
that encapsulates the journey of
wilderness survival it takes a long time
and when you get to the end of it it
doesn't feel like it went by fast it
does feel I can spin out a long journey
you know sometimes like boy that went
right by not survival not wilderness you
get to the end of it you feel weathered
you feel tough and you feel like you've
been on a long journey that was my
breakdown thanks for watching